mom doesn't like big surprises I do
let's do it let's don't do it
seventh Heaven star Lorenzo brainy has
died at the age of 21 last Monday the
child actor lost control of his Toyota
Camry and struck a pole while driving in
California's San Bernardino County
Lorenzo was pronounced dead at the scene
the 21 year old starred as Sam Camden on
the WB series ash Kevin he'd know yeah
he would know and counted Jill stinks
Lorenzo was a quadruplet and he and his
siblings were all casted on the show
when they were just five months old
together they shared the roles of twins
Sam and David from 1999 to 2001 after
that year only Lorenzo and Nicholas
continued to play the roles until seven
heavens end in 2007 the family drama
aired for 11 seasons and also starred
Jessica Biel and Beverly Mitchell
Beverly mourn the loss on Instagram
writing my heart is broken for his
family so many fun memories watching
them grow up
rest in peace so you were full of light
and will not be forgotten
Lorenzo sister shared a touching tribute
to him on Instagram writing saying that
you were a blessing is an understatement
you brought light to so many lives and
you did so much with the too short of a
life that you had and his friend made a
youtube video showing all their memories
he wrote we were blessed to have Lorenzo
Bree knows beautiful soul in our lives
the amount of people he touched with his
character and charm was unbelievable he
was a loyal friend and an amazing
brother he would always get my back no
matter what
rest in peace brother
[Music]
you